coming this summer the story of Batman's
greatest ally and best friend in the
whole world
the movie is time to clean up this city
that actually does look pretty good
[Music]
they're really making movies about every
superhero has there been a movie about
you it was a Green Lantern movie but we
don't we don't talk about that it's time
they make one about me I'm afraid no I
only make movies about real superheroes
why don't they take us seriously Titans
you guys are never actually doing
anything heroic wasn't even a crime and
you didn't save anything we save design
having a movie is the only way to be
seen as a real hero what about an
arch-nemesis
[Music]
stop right there
Deadpool Deadpool what why does
everybody think I'm Deadpool
I thought Deadpool was a good guy by the
way he should be saying that he's not me
okay cuz I came out like way before he
did now I'm pretty sure you're Deadpool
we can make you more arch-nemesis
finding a sea that we're worthy of a
movie fighting a bunch of sidekicks and
a half a robot
oh man I'm never letting you fly my body
again under my control
destroy
must be we're taking you down how are
you gonna do it really the part of me
you wanna dance off you're gonna annoy
me to death with your waffles
[Music]